Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
just checking in on you.
Are you doing, sorry.
It's like eight 15 in the morning. My
wife's gonna fucking kill me. I'm sorry.
It's eight 39. All right, so on the
other side, eight 30. You don't,
let's take those construction rules.
You can't hammer a nail
until 7:00 AM I can't yell.
I'm just checking in on you until,
uh, after eight 30 in the morning.
That's the deal that we have. All
right. Um, what's going on? How were,
how was your, your, um, your in
between Christmas and New Year's?
Do you guys get the time off?
You know,
I know the kids do kids on break,
you know,
just in time to fucking run into
that chick from high school,
you always try to beg, give it a
shot, right? Everybody else did.
You have to go to work on the 26th
and the 27th year right there.
You're right back.
It's the fucking worst.
Everybody should be off.
You shouldn't even be able to
buy food this time of year.
Everything is fucking closed.
Everybody just sit down,
fucking relax. You know,
take a week for yourselves.
We could this fucking country,
man, we gotta be more like Europe.
I don't know how they do it over there
with their fucking God damn skinny jeans.
You know they fucking legs are skinny
as their arms over there and those tall
people, countries, you know
the Scandinavian countries,
you know down in the Mediterranean,
these motherfuckers,
they get like six weeks vacation a year.
It's fucking incredible.
Why don't we do that?
Huh?
President to be Donald Trump.
You want to make this country great?
You can make this country what?
It never fucking had six
weeks of vacation every,
you know fucking ah,
that would be good one.
How great would that be?
Every two months you just get a week off,
right? Then you work for seventh lucky
seven. You work for seven fucking weeks.
Then you get a week off and just sit
there and fucking chill out and start,
you know, let all the stress of
your job go fucking start over.
Everybody is off at the same time.
Cops,
pilots, you know, people who watch
the nuclear fucking facilities,
you just, you know, it's not
good. Not that's going to
happen. Right. What's this?
The Simpsons? It's fine.
Everybody just chill. Even a war.
That's it. Every fucking
seven weeks. Boom.
Right?
Several weeks you try to kill
each other and then, you know,
right when it hits the eighth week,
somebody stands up out of that trench.
[inaudible] oh really? I
oh,
Liz.
Oh right. He just fucking
chill up. This is it.
This is basically the deal.
I am mom really trying to,
uh, I think I'm going to
fucking talk to somebody.
I got to fucking get my
temper under control because
I don't want to be an angry
dad. Uh, I want to break this cycle.
Um, so somebody told me
yesterday, they go, well,
why don't you try metta meditation?
And I got the fuck out of here.
That works. And the person was like, yeah,
I do it twice a day for 20 minutes.
And uh,
like I'm going to have the time to do
that when I have a fucking kid. Uh,
twice a day for 20 minutes.
And um,
he said like, if you just
meditate, shut your brain off,
your body just starts getting rid
of stress. And I asked him, I said,
this has made you less angry.
He said much less angry.
So I'm going to give that a shot and
I'm going to talk to somebody, you know,
I've been cleaning up all my shit,
trying to get rid of a bunch of stuff
and I found this empty notebook and I was
like, all right, this is going to be
like my fucking angry journal, you know,
figure out, oh my God.
Yesterday I got the, you know,
the amount of shit that I just,
I just completely,
I go from zero to 9,000 fucking degrees.
Um,
you know,
yesterday I pulled up and there was
some guy fucking parked in the top of my
driveway cause yet another thing
was fucked up with my house.
They tell you guys the awning
fucking broke. It's just,
it just never fucking ends. It just
never this fucking house. It never rents.
I just find myself, I feel like I'm
a running in a giant circle that I'm,
once I get everything fucking
fixed, you know, 360 degrees,
rotisserie fucking, uh, uh,
whatever the fuck rebuild
of this fucking house.
The second I do the last thing,
the first thing I fixed is going to break
and it's just going to start all over
again. So, um, anyways, I'm
going to try to do that.
And um,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious is like when
I actually am calm and I am relaxed,
it actually makes my wife nervous
in a way. Like not like nervous,
like she's afraid I'm going to do
something. She's just like, she's like,
are you a everything okay
with you? Uh, what's,
what's going on with you? It's just like
nothing. I'm just quiet and relaxing.
She's this. Yeah. Are you okay.
So, um, I got to dial
it way the fuck down.
You know,
I think my average energy you ever played
like pickup whatever sport and there's
always that person taking it way too
seriously in before the game even starts.
They skate up next to you or are they
stand next a post up or whatever,
you can just feel their fucking
energy and you're just like, Oh God,
not this fucking guy. I hate to
admit it, but I think I'm that guy,
except I'm not playing a sport.
I'm just fucking walking around my house.
MMM.
I Dunno what the fuck it is, but uh,
I have to work on that shit. So, um,
as I've been mentioning, you guys have
been getting rid of a ton of shit.
MMM.
You know, selling stuff, having a
buddy mind sell it on craigslist,
trying to take as little as
I can to goodwill because
I really believe that they
just fill that fucking truck up with 90%
of the shit, just throw it in the ocean.
So I'm actually trying
to sell it to people. Um,
just the sheer amount of shit that
people bring down to goodwill.
Like people use goodwill,
you know what I mean?
Without ever addressing their fucking
consumerism. And I did it too,
like how much shit I bought and just
how every time you leave the house,
she come home with something else in a
bag and then it's just in your fucking
house. Like when me and Nia first moved
in with two people in a fucking house,
I mean, it was like echo, echo, and
all of a sudden, five years later,
it's fucking filled up. I'm
like, what? What happened?
How did we become these
people? So Woo Woo. So I'm,
I'm, I'm getting rid of
like all of this clutter.
Uh,
you
know, like I have every fucking laptop
just about that I've ever fucking had.
I've always kept them because I dunno,
like I always hear that, you know,
they end up in junk yards and something
leaks out of him. And I'm like, well,
why don't I just leave it in my fucking
closet? It's not hurting anything.
It's just sitting there and then I
got to where there, then I got three,
then I got four.
So a,
I'm going to try to find a place
that recycles them responsibly. Um,
so anyways, throughout
all of this, people go,
you gotta check out this documentary,
these guys, the minimalists.
And um,
I started to watch it the other night and,
uh, I'm totally on
board. It's what I want.
And I'm watching it with the [inaudible].
It's fucking hilarious is I
can feel her getting annoyed.
And I'm like, yeah, you watching this
shit? She goes, yeah. She goes, you know,
I don't, you know, I like my stuff,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I kept poking at it to see what the
deal was. And she was finally just like,
yeah,
I just don't give a shit about a bunch
of white people that are all excited that
they're now living with like absolutely
nothing. You know, they, they, you know,
if they fucking fuck did she put it?
She goes,
there's a lot of people live in like
that not out of there wasn't a choice.
Right. And I was like, Oh, Jesus Christ,
we're going to go down that fucking road.
We actually had a great
conversation. I was like, you know,
there's a certain kind of white person
that fucking annoys the shit out of you.
She goes, no, there it's
like, yeah, there is.
It's still white person that is not
happy in life. It is trying to, to,
to figure out what true
happiness is because the
stereotype of a white person is
that they just show in all their
dreams come true. All right.
These are just a group of people
that were living away certain way.
It wasn't making them happy.
They tried something new,
it made them happy and they
just want to share it with you.
And this is why my wife says
shit. She goes, hi. Now that
you put it that way, okay,
fair enough. I was being judgmental
but blah, blah blah. We came,
we came to a good place, but
it was fucking, she went,
I wish you guys could have heard she
went on one of her fucking epic rants.
I was dying laughing because I,
I heard the element of truth in it.
But um, I dunno if there is all of
that shit though. There is that,
that fuck it thing.
How every group of people is like defined.
Yeah.
You know, by a negative. And uh,
yeah.
You know, I guess with white
people is that, you know,
we have yachts and were raised by
the maid who's not white and uh,
whatever we want we get and then we screw
it up and then our parents come in and
save us cause they know the judge,
you know, and that's definitely,
that's an option as a white
person, but that's, you know,
you've really slicing off
the top of the ham there.
Anyways. Um, so
yeah,
this is going to be the new me,
you know, let's see how long,
who the fuck's kid who, let's see
a long, I can sustain this. Okay.
Because the reality is is
you are who the fuck you are.
And I am a wound up son of a bitch and um,
I'm going to try to unwind as much as
I can for as long as I can before I go
back into that deep groove than I've
worn into how my brain is functioned.
A,
I'm going to try to fucking meditate.
I'm going to get rid of
all of this fucking shit
that I have accumulated.
MMM.
You know,
for years already I've gone to like
comedy events and stuff and they're always
giving you like this gift bag
of it's and it's shit shit.
It just, you know, I don't know
what the fuck I have to shit.
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
Little things that jelly beans with
the fucking festivals name on it,
some toiletries, some
travel bag shit, you know,
all in a little bag that has the logo,
the thing on it. And you're like,
I gotta keep this,
you know,
part of my scrapbook that I
don't fucking have and I just,
when I started to do is I just say no.
I say no.
And then if it gets weird and
they had this vibe of like, Hey,
I'm trying to give you a gift
here and you're turning it down.
I kind of feel insulted me a little bit.
Kind of insulted me a little bit here.
I will take the bag and then what I
do is I come home and then I just,
I give it to somebody. Hey, no, I
just did the stay of techie show.
You don't want it. Yeah. Take it,
take it, get it the fuck outta here.
And what's funny too is actually not
when you go out and you try and sell your
shit, you realize how little fucking
value it has. You know what I mean?
Um, I dunno. And I should tell you when,
as I sell this shit have an element of
guilt and I always think of that movie.
What about Bob? When that therapist's
pass Bob onto Richard Dreyfus,
that's what I feel like I'm doing with
my stuff is I'm selling it to these
people. I'm just looking at
him and say by, and I'm like,
you're not gonna fucking use that.
It's your problem now buddy.
Um, so anyways, that's what I've
been, uh, that's what I'm doing.
I got to a,
I have to chill way the fuck out,
um, for the next 18 to 22
years, evidently. And uh,
so I imagine I'll get some tweets.
Don't you think that's going to
hurt your comedy? No, I don't.
I've been fucking up my life
for almost half a century.
I have plenty of drawn and just the
fact of someone being his wound up as me
trying to walk around and act like,
you know,
wearing a sweater and laughing at small
talk is going to do it for me. Right.
Right there that there'll
be something in that. Right.
Well maybe you weren't thinking that.
Maybe that's what I'm worried about and
I'm saying that you're saying it so I
don't look like I'm on fucking
weak on some level. Um, so anyways.
All right. Jesus Christ's I've
just been fucking babbling.
Like some chick on one of these
fucking shows booked bill.
Maybe you got a little
fucking reality chicken.
You ever think that was fucking God
damn cough ever go away. I'm sorry.
Let's do that again. You know, I
find it really irritating that I uh,
took some medication for a cough a long
time ago, but a month ago and I haven't,
and not smoking cigars. I am getting
a good night's sleep and I just,
for some reason in order
to do this is my wife, uh,
is so pregnant right now that
she doesn't remotely get cold.
So the fucking heat has been
off in the house all day.
I walk around with like a sweatshirt
on. I just looked at, I go,
you're not cold at all.
Like my feet are fucking free.
Like we literally in the house, it's
like a log cabin. There's like no,
no heat on whatsoever.
Even hear it.
Now I've got around the background
cause she's fucking upstairs. Right. Um,
but like,
you know,
I got this old house and they got these
cool fucking old windows and I don't
want to get rid of them because they
don't make them like that anymore.
But the wind just fucking passes through.
Oh,
the wind just goes right through my
fucking house. I swear to Christ.
It's unbelievable.
Only thing missing is just like leaves
just blowing by when I'm in the fucking
living room. So I'm always
cranking up the fucking hate.
She starts looking like she's under
like 20 blankets. So I have to,
she know what the deal is. As a
guy, you're going to fucking lose.
You fucking lose. Why do I keep
trying to turn on my computer? Like,
like I actually have internet
connections down here. Um, all right,
let's get into the point where
I've got to read some of these. Uh,
some of these fucking reads here.
I've got a doctor's
appointment with my wife today.
Stupid fucking you've got to go to as
a guy and when he be there,
no one's going to fucking, uh,
no one's going to talk to
you at all. But uh, you know,
we still need you to be here because
I haven't been to like the last two.
They weren't important once,
you know,
they just sort of check up things and
like she, she's the only everybody saying,
where's your husband?
Where's your husband?
We miss not talking to him when he's here.
All right, let's do some
reads here. Wink, wink.
W. I. N. C as in cat. Finding
great new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you
all about our sponsor, Columbia,
the of Debbie looking for weapons of
mass destruction and how they make it so
easy to get wine personalized to your
palate and delivered right to your door.
And here's a little update for you club.
Debbie at Daddy,
let me best is now called Winc,
spelled w. I. N. C as in cat,
a new name and an improved looked.
But here's the important thing.
It's still the same amazing wine
company introducing you to new wines.
You'll love wink. W. I. N.
C as in cock works directly with wine
makers and growers from all over the world
to create delicious wine to deliver it
right to your door. You're fucking drunk.
Winks 100% satisfaction guarantee means
if you don't like a bottle they send you,
they'll replace it with a bottle.
You'll love no questions asked. Well,
there you go. You're cheap fox, suck
the thing down. I'd be like, Eh,
didn't really like it. Then you get
another one. That's the old twofer.
You just don't, uh, you don't
just get random bottles. Wink,
Wy and C as in Cox is personalized
wine membership that reminds wines that
recommends wine specifically for you based
on the results of your palate profile
quiz. There's some big brother's
shit you can also wrote.
You can also rate all of the
wine you receive from wink.
So they'll learn about you with every
order and constantly personalize wine they
send.
Sign up for Winc right now.
W I N C is clitoris right now.
And gain immediate.
So childish. Bill, why do
you keep doing? You know why?
Because it's funny and it's making you
listen to the whole fucking ad, isn't it?
Immediate insiders to gain immediate
insider access to the best fine wine from
all around the world. Fun. Oh my
God. This the infidels. Delicious.
Find out for yourself why yours truly
and thousands of other satisfied wine
lovers are raving about Winc. I'm
not ready. I'm reading the copy.
I don't drink wine. It gives me a brutal
fucking hangover. The best part I,
you know what? If I have
a nice meal, you know,
and I something from fucking Blue Apron,
maybe I'll have a glass of wine right of
Nia has one of her fucking friends over.
Everybody's sitting around, they
got the fire going. You know,
you always feel like you're in the big
chill when your wife has friends over.
The best part wink is over, is offering
my listeners $20 off right now.
When you go to try winc.com/burr
they'll even cover the shipping.
Think about
it.
Are you done?
Thank you. You'll get fine wine
personalized to your palate.
We get it delivered right to your fucking
door. You just said this shit. Try Winc.
W I n C
as in cynical. It's on
you. Spell cynical. Is it,
isn't it with an s o s and c one?
Are you guys gonna just fucking combined,
you know like,
like one of those Dunkin donuts pizza hut.
Thanks a try.
Winc and get $20 off complimentary
shipping right now when you try a,
when you go to try winc.com/bird that's
w I n C as in cat.com/ [inaudible]
oh blue apron everybody.
Uh Huh.
You know, not all ingredients
are created equal. Now Jesus,
it's just like the Klu Klux
Klan is fucking food thing.
Fresh high quality ingredients. They
didn't say that. Make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Why don't fucking really raise people,
say Hawaii white people,
h W. I t. E a genuine,
quite gold. Talk about your
personal experience. Fuck you.
Affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes.
Would you like some pumpkin pie with pre
portioned ingredients to make delicious
home cooked meals for rioty?
Choose from a variety of new recipes each
week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you.
Recipes are not repeated with any years,
so you never get to get bored.
Flexible.
Customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose what fits your needs.
And there's no weekly commitment,
so you only get this one,
so you only get deliveries
when you want them.
I'm going to do how they
sing in my church. Easy.
Each meal comes with step by step,
easy to follow recipe card,
pre portioned ingredients and
prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Guarantee blew a prince
freshness guarantee.
Promises that every ingredient in your
delivery already ready to cook or they'll
make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/
[inaudible] you'll love how good it feels
and tastes to create incredible
home cooked meals with
blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook. You know what?
That's a great way to get in shape too.
You know [inaudible] easy to cook meals.
You come home,
you fucking put it together before
you do something dumb, you know,
like order a pizza. Then I
have some ice cream, right?
And a spoon with a fat guy, you know,
and his fatness. Just fucking, you know,
you ever done the spoon with the
fat guy just makes you fatter.
That's a true story. Um, all right,
where the fuck am I in this podcast?
20 fucking minutes.
And you know something,
some days it doesn't feel like
work in other days it does.
This is one of these days.
Um,
what do think Obama's thinking right now?
I always think like this time of year,
this time, like when a president is in
their second term, it's fucking December.
Okay,
you've got another couple of weeks before
the next fucking poor bastard comes in
there. You know, and I do meet bastard
cause it's always going to be a,
but it's always going to be a guide.
Ladies always going to be a guy.
All right?
That job is for a man.
There's certain things that men can't
do and there's certain things that women
can't do and women can do a bunch of
things, but running the country is,
is just not one of those things.
I mean people are gonna just gonna take
that clip and take all the fucking,
you know, I'm just fucking
around of it. Out of there.
Is he saying that women's,
um,
hey, what do you call those? Youtube
fucking stars, those fucking cunts.
You know like when like that guy punched
the kangaroo in the face and you want
to see it and you go to click on it.
And then this is just
this fucking high energy.
20 something Douche with the
Janet Jackson fucking microphone.
Can I take your order?
Please? Go on. Okay guys,
so you don't get to believe it's
okay. See this carrying a root. Okay.
We're all familiar with the kangaroo
and then they cut to some shit about
Kangaroos and they just take this
fucking, this fucking clip. It's,
it's like, it's like, dude,
I don't fucking need you.
I know what's going to happen to show
me the original clip and these fucking
cunts insert themselves into it.
And then they,
they making like 250 grand, a Goddamn
fucking video of some shit. You know,
they like the DJ's
of Youtube.
Yeah. Way Do, do, do,
do, do, do to do, to,
to do the same fucking thing they're
doing that they fucking remix in this shit
that take another people.
I don't even know what deejaying is.
I have no fucking idea.
I don't even know why I make fun of boy.
Yeah you do bill,
because you got to fuck in a half
hour to fill up here. Um, anyway,
so did I mention I was,
I've been trying to do the impossible.
I can't remember if I
already talked about this.
I'm trying to watch like every Bruin
game and every Celtic game this year
cause you got to choose you either a
basketball guy or a hockey guy and I been
trying to watch the other night I
watched a Bruins game and then a then a
fucking Celtic game.
I watched the um,
I don't know if I already talked about
this cause I fucked up the podcast and I
just started again. I don't give a shit.
I watch the Bruins lose four to three,
to the blue jackets and then I watch
the Celtics after that beat the uh,
Memphis Grizzlies. I believe I already
talked about this. I have no idea.
All I know is the fucking
NFL playoffs are coming up.
Does anything repeat anything go by faster
then the fucking
NFL regular season,
you know it goes by faster.
My fucking train of thought.
I was talking about
presidents this time of year.
You know how fucking site that would
be after eight fucking years of being
president. The stress of that,
the fucking stress of that.
All the bodies, all the people that died
because of the decisions that you made,
it's fucking inevitable.
Okay. Cause you answer,
you answered to the, the, the
reptilian people at the top.
You know,
and I don't mean shape shifters,
I just mean people who do not give a
fuck about anything but themselves and
their money and power. That's all they
care about. They don't care who suffers.
They don't give a shit.
They don't believe in God.
They believe that their God or
they believe that God is fucking,
you know,
bestowed them with this
great responsibility to run
the fucking world to try to
take over it or whatever.
Right. I always just think like,
as much as Obama doesn't
want to see Trump,
he has to be so fucking site.
You know,
like if I was a bomber right
now, I would just be like, dude,
I'm getting all the
fucking sports packages.
I'll get myself a pair of silk
fucking pajamas, you know,
with sheepskin fucking slippers
and I'm not doing shit. I am not going
to do fine, but they have to do shit.
You know why? Because the president
only makes 500 grand and fucking year.
So now what he has to do is now
for the rest of his fucking life,
he has to go out and give these
speeches. Okay. Which is, you know,
to the people that put him in office,
they pay him like six fucking figures
to get out there and tell his fucking
jokes and do his little song and dance.
And the reality is,
is that just washing their
fucking bribe money, you know,
so he would push through all the shit
that they wanted or as much of it as they
could while he was in office. And then
they also get to see like, yet, see,
we own this guy,
you know,
is it bringing new lizards into their
fucking dead to me? Like, see this,
we actually have former presidents come
here and do a little song and dance for
us. You know why? Because
we own this fucking guy.
We owned them before you even fucking went
in there. We own the fucking next guy.
You know, that's probably why, you know,
as much as the upper 1% probably did not
want to see Donald Trump get in there
because he's this fucking road guy and
all you fucking progressive lefties glow.
I got to say,
shut the fuck up.
They're actually gonna end up love in
that guy because it seems what he wants to
do is deregulate everything because
guys at his level of wealth,
this so fucking rich,
they find the government annoying.
I have to answer it. A Ho who's at
the door, the u s government, uh,
these fucking assholes. They
opened the door. What, what,
what now? Oh, you know, just
uh,
you know,
kind of appreciated for as the way the
u s government talks to that level of
wealth because they need them to get
into fucking office. Right. You know,
kind of appreciate if a, you know, you
wouldn't build that golf course, uh,
over that homeless shelter and those
native Americans, you know that,
you know what? I don't know. I'll think
about it. I'll think about it. All right.
Just fucking go fuck yourself.
I do what I want.
Yeah.
I'm making money off opiates.
Shut the fuck up.
I don't know. I'm a, I don't know. I don't
know what to tell you, but you know what?
I'm in fucking limbo right
now is where I am. Um,
I haven't been doing stand up. I can't
go out. I can't really leave the house.
I'm afraid to fucking leave
the house because you know, I,
I stay within like a
certain fucking radius.
So if my wife does not have our kid,
uh,
by January 2nd,
I am going to the rose bowl and I am
going to do the unspeakable at there.
I am going to be sober as a church mouse.
I won't even smoke a cigar because I have
to let those fucking things go because
I have to get life insurance
and, uh, I don't want to pay the,
I'm a smoker and I don't
want to be a smoker.
You know what I'll fucking smoke like
for a year. That's what I think. Oh,
well I enjoy the fucking shit out
of those. Uh, yeah, dude, I'm,
I'm getting to that point in my life. I'm
getting my affairs in order. You know?
It's actually,
it's,
you know what I've actually found going
through the whole process of getting
life insurance and putting together a
trust and a will and all of that Shit,
I've actually found that to be just as
enjoyable is getting rid of all this shit
in my life. All the clutter. It's the
same thing like this, you know, as a guy,
I think there's something like how we
just don't deal with our mortality and,
uh, so you don't want to think about it,
but I gotta tell you once, you just like,
you think you're like, yeah, okay. And
something happens to me. You get this,
you get debt. And I'm fucking out.
Right. And nobody is, you know,
nobody has to worry about anything. And
then they can't be like, you know what,
that son of a bitch, I don't know what he
was doing a swimming with those sharks.
But uh, I gotta tell you he'd say
one thing about that guy, you know,
he had his affairs in order.
Yeah.
You got to be that guy. If you have
any sort of wife, children, anything,
you got it. You got to get your
fucking affairs in order. And um,
I haven't done it like a lot of my
friends didn't and none of them had their
affairs in order and a
number of them died. And uh,
that is just a fucking thing.
I'm telling you right now.
You do not want to put your
fucking family through that.
And I'm not going to be that guy,
so hopefully I won't die before. Uh,
I get everything all fucking
straight down here. But that is my,
that's my first thing
I'm going to do in the,
in 2017 I'm going to prepare my affairs.
May Affairs will be in order. Oh God,
this is gonna be so weird. You know,
so weird about getting life insurance
as you then give your partner motive.
You know, my wife doesn't
have fucking life insurance.
She doesn't even think about it. They
don't give a fuck about us. Right.
And you know, one, I don't want her
to have life insurance, you know,
because then I got to deal with
the cops. If something came, lol.
Didn't you make fucking six figures when
she fell down that flight of stairs?
I swear to God,
I was by myself.
I was playing drums in a rehearsal space.
You know,
I spent so much time alone every day
that I would never have a fucking alibi.
God forbid if something ever
happened. Can Anybody, uh,
can anybody vouch for you
that that's where you were at?
And then I would have to go into my head.
Who did I yell at on the way there or
the way back in a fucking car that I get
their license plate so I
can call them up and say,
do you remember that bald red
bearded asshole who screamed at you?
You know? Yeah. That you
remember that you can,
do you remember what time of day that was?
This is really critical for me.
Um, yeah, it's, it's a very bizarre
thing to go out and uh, it's,
it's, it's uh, makes you feel at
peace and then also, you know,
it makes you, you know, when
your wife, you know, brings
over, you're like some food,
you kind of looking at her,
then you're looking at the
food, you know, she gets up,
you switch plates.
I think I've watched too many of
those first 48, you know what I mean?
I love those guys to where they,
they fucking,
their first two wives die mysteriously
and then someone else fucking Mary's.
It's just like,
this is the fucking thing.
You can marry somebody who
had one person die. Okay.
That happens. Unfortunately that
fucking happens. But once they're there,
they're at to get the fuck away
from that person. What are the,
what are the fucking odds, you
know, you got married in both,
your husband's died, he
married twice. They, I'm a,
I'm a two time widower. We at,
well you're not going to be a three time
the fuck away from me. Check please.
Right. Gives that hacky fucking out
to every comedy scene. I'll just,
I'll have what she's having. Um, yeah
you gotta get the fuck out of there.
You know you can only have one spouse die.
And after that,
if I was running shit, if I was one of
the Lizard people and I was running shit,
this would be the rule. Anybody who
had two spouses die and you know,
we can't prove that you fucking did it.
You are only allowed to date
other people that had that,
that are already had two people
die. Okay. And then you know,
yeah
whoever dies in that who gives a shit
cause then you just got rid of one murder
in psycho and then you just keep having
them date each other and eventually then
there's only one and then you stick
that person in a giant like human,
like perky cage and like the scary,
it's there's the winter or this.
She is right.
All 48 of her husband's died
mysteriously can never prove it.
You know,
take it down and put her on Coney island.
Does that still exist?
That fucking rollercoaster.
You ever go to Coney island goal?
Net one, that fucking rollercoaster.
It's one of the scariest fucking rides
I've ever been on that because it's,
it's like a scary ride.
It's because the ride is so fucking old
and there's no padding in this seat.
I swear to God,
I got off that ride.
I felt like I was in a fucking
three car accident. You know,
my fucking back was killing me.
My shoulder was fucked up.
MMM.
I don't know.
You don't.
I'm probably fucking up my life right now
cause I'm trying to do too many things
at once as I always do. I'm going
to meditate. I'm going to do yoga.
I'm going to fucking eh, stop yelling. I'm
gonna, I'm gonna go to therapy and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. I think I'm
freaking out because I'm a fucking,
a volatile fucking loony
ticket and I don't want a,
I don't want to be that person.
You know? You know what?
I want to be able to be like fucking
Joe Pesci in casino. You know,
minus watching my brother getting
beaten to death in a Cornfield,
like not that part. The part where he's
making pancakes for his kid, you know,
despite the fact he squeezed somebody's
eyeball out in a vice like 20 minutes
earlier than he could come home, he could
shut it off. It was very inspirational.
Like, Hey, you want some more syrup?
I, you know, I love you. Right.
Kisses him on the head,
you know, and that's it.
Then he goes out and he fucking
kneecap somebody's, you know,
20 seconds after the bus drives away
with his kid. That's who I want to be.
All right, man. That's it.
That's the podcast. Um,
and I got to admit, you know,
it's been hard for me to watch a,
the Bruins this year, man. So I've
actually been watching more NBA hoop,
which I'm really fucking embarrassed to
say because I've always been a hockey
guy, but you know, I will
always be occupy, but it's also,
I can't ignore watching what Danny
Ainge is doing. It's fucking great.
There's so much fun to watch. Um, so
you know what, let's look up here.
Who Do we got next? I don't know who the
Celtics have next, but you guys here,
Aaron Kaufman is leaving fucking
gas monkey fast, fast and loud.
It's fucking brutal.
But the way a discovery talked about it,
it sounded like he was going to get
his own show, but it's just like,
what the fuck? I don't want to see
that. I want to see this spinoff.
You know
the Vernon Shirley were on happy days.
That was one of the,
one of the best times ever, and then
they got their own show wasn't as good.
It's like when a super group breaks up
and then the lead singer does their thing
and then the other bag gets a new,
since like Van Halen,
David Lee Roth was never better
than when he was in Van Halen.
Van Halen was never better than
when David Lee Roth was there.
You know what I mean? Sammy Hagar
was better when he was by himself.
What are you talking about, Bill? I don't
know. Just fucking talking. Oh, you know,
I'm just listening. All right, Bruins.
What do we got next? Duh, Duh, Duh,
Duh, Duh, Duh. To to, ah,
we got a home and all,
I'm against the fucking buffalo sabers.
I never understood that home at home.
It's a home and an away.
Who is this fucking Hitler youth
that they got number 55 on defense?
Risto, Laney had, we're
still laden. Jesus Christ.
Tell me his grandfather doesn't
live down in fucking South America.
Ah, let's it all Nazi fucking
hundred joke. All right,
we're going to end on that.
Um, that's the podcast for this week.
Uh, um, just checking in on you.
That's all the fuck it was in. If
you guys want to, uh, you know,
keep listening to here.
We're going to play a little fucking
music and you're going to listen to some,
uh, some greatest hits from a podcast
gone by in a time. I can't remember.
All right. Have a great weekend. You
constant. I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
Yay.
Go.
[inaudible]
oh,
just
[inaudible].
Um, new year's everybody. Here
we go. Dear Billy, ball drop.
I'm not going to ask you what you're
doing on New Year's cause I already know
you and your Rosebowl crew will be tap
dancing at the Wiltern over there. Uh,
I'm going to be there with
a girl. I'm 50% into. Okay,
well then that affects what you should
be buying her that night. He goes,
she's cool, she's hot and I don't
have any major complaints about her.
I'm also not in love with her and really
can't see anything beyond hooking up.
My plan is to laugh my ass off and see
what happens. All right, if we hook up,
that's great. If not, no big deal, dude.
You're in the zone. You're in the zone.
This is some Dimone shit. You don't
care if she comes, stays laser praise.
Now you've got the attitude. Um, I don't,
I told two friends and they boast,
advised against hooking up with her.
All right, well I don't know your friends
and I don't know what their motive is.
Let's see if you explained this.
Here he goes,
I would never let that decide
whether or not I would.
But the interesting thing is that they
both said independent of each other,
that hooking with a girl on
New Year's Eve,
Mike,
give her the wrong impression at t and
that she's going to be a leach afterwards.
Oh, that's fucking, that's just
fear mongering. That's bullshit.
What has your finger on is the ball drops.
All of a sudden you have a relationship.
I had a good time, had some laughs,
so like you don't want to go
to the farmer's market now.
I don't have something against
farmers markets. Not really.
Well do you want as you where
to go cause you know I don't,
I don't feel like going with you.
I don't feel like a spark your fucking
ass off for what being honest I have.
Fuck you there. It's, it's the end of
the relationship. Anyways, he goes,
I can't even fathom why New Year's Eve
would be be considered a special occasion
that would lead to her thinking that this
whole topic is ridiculous and I can't
even stand to waste time talking about it.
But I wanted to hear your opinion.
I think I just gave it to you. My question
to you is, do you agree with that?
And also,
do you think there are any days on the
calendar that would make a girl think you
were into her? Oh yeah. If you
took around on Valentine's Day.
Yeah, it's about it. Valentine's Day.
Valentine's Day that that would be
good. What else? What other day?
Saint Patrick's Day?
Yeah.
You know, you sitting there eating
a fucking meat pie next door,
hammered out of your mind with a green
plastic had on hi Vic. He really likes me.
Um,
the key and if I could,
if I could do my single life over again
is I would have been way less fearful to
be honest.
You know,
when relationships were starting,
you know,
uh, women are not as psycho is you think,
I mean, a lot of times when
you say that women are psycho,
it's because you were being
deceptive and uh, yeah.
Then they go fucking psycho.
Yeah, they definitely do. But you,
a lot of times creative if you just
tell them straight up front when they're
like, so what is this?
And just be like, look,
I'm not looking to get in a
relationship right now or like, listen,
I enjoy your company,
but I'm not feeling like this spark.
Like there's something to that next level.
I just feel like you should know that.
And you'd be surprised at
how well they take that.
You know, they, it's not
that always, you know,
if you say that the second you feel it,
it's usually pretty early on.
So there's no really deep feelings and
that's all people just don't want to get
hurt. Okay. Believe me, I heard a
lot of fucking people believe me.
And um, so that's what I
learned. I remember one, um,
Jesus Christ years ago
and I was just a lad living in New York.
I remember I hooked up with this, this
woman, and she was just like, you know,
so what is this? Where's this going? And
I was just like, uh, nowhere. I'm like,
fucking 12 was I 35? She was 23. I'm like,
I'm like 12 years old. And then you,
you know, by the time you took 30,
I'm going to be like 60.
What do you think it's going is?
She actually laughed and I was
just like, you know, she goes,
so what are we doing? But they're
just hanging out, having fun.
So whatever crazy thing you want to try,
but you don't want to do it with
your husband, do it with me.
And that was it. And she was
just like, all right, cool.
We had fun for a few weeks
and then that was fucking it.
And nobody got hurt and uh,
you know,
lost touch with her and that was it. No
harm, no foul. Had a great fucking time.
So there's no light,
but look,
you take them out on Valentine's Day
and you get them a rose and all of that
shit. You start leading them on. So what
you're really talking to, I feel he's,
you're talking to younger
guys like me probably at that,
like meet like how I was, I mean,
how am I trying to say this?
You're talking to two guys who
had their age right now. I,
their skill level was what my skill level
was where they don't know how to set
it up. So they're sitting
there going, oh, don't do this.
Don't bring them out on this day.
Cause that makes them think this. Um,
oh that says to me is that they don't
know how to communicate what's going on.
So they feel like they,
and they're also in that thing where
they feel like they have to fucking throw
their jacket over a mud puddle and let
them walk on it in order to get fucked
that night. Which you don't.
You just have to be honest.
Because women enjoy sex too,
and they also enjoy you telling them
what the fucking deal is. All right,
so there you go.
So you don't have anything.
Don't worry about
[inaudible].
[inaudible] Hey, what's going on? It is,
and this is the Monday morning podcast.
Welcome.
Welcome. If you're new to it. I do
one of these every single Monday.
I answer questions.
People email me, questions
people send me in there. A
underrated, overrated lists,
things that they feel are underrated,
things that they feel are overrated
and a new year's resolution.
That's what we're doing this week,
Huh? That's what we're doing.
This is like the sixth time I've
tried to start doing this podcast.
I don't know what the fuck's going on
with me this week. It's 10 in the morning.
I think I started too early.
I don't know why I started so early.
I have the ability to hang up at
this point and I could just erase it,
but for some reason I'm just,
I'm plowing through on this one.
Holy Shit. He's had a dog fight, I think
two dogs and fighting. You hear that?
You get that shit.
The fuck is with that dog.
The owner doesn't do shit about it.
Let's see what this dog looks like.
Let's describe both people as
they come up the street. Okay.
That's kind of a fat person or
those people who wears that,
that you know those hats, like it looks
like you're going to be playing tennis,
but you're not.
She has the one of those hats.
She's got one of those
little fucking terriers,
miserable fucking dog and they're
getting into some sort of a,
a little Volkswagen Gulf.
Wow.
That's a picture for
you, Huh? What or the,
where the fuck did those dreams
go off the road? I hate dogs,
man. I love him, but I fucking hate him.
I've been talking about how I'm going to
get a bulldog and now I don't know if I
can do it. I think just
as a man, you just,
they just look awesome and then I'm
watching youtube clips of them and they're
just a genetic fucking
mess. They, they, I,
I'm watching these, these youtube
videos, the dog snoring or
I can't deal with that.
That'd be like, you know,
my dad's used to snore like that and I,
I wanted to kill him.
He trying to watch the game and he would
like fall asleep and just start snoring.
And I literally would think about
taking off one of my, you know,
the eighties back when tube socks
were a lot longer. And I was like,
I can choke them with
this, you know, and, uh,
that's my own dad can have a
fucking dog with sleep apnea,
you know,
bulldogs when they sleep,
they sound like they used to
play offensive line in the NFL.
You know what I mean?
You have is
they got to sleep upright in a chair
that's not a fucking dog. It's like a,
it's just a blob. You
know, I got like 18 stairs.
You've got to climb up into my apartment.
Things are going to have a fucking heart
attack. And then what do I gotta do?
I gotta give them doggy fucking CPR.
Jesus Christ.
I just love the face.
Is there a fucking dog out
there that has that bulldog face
that can breathe
but can actually exist in an apartment?
I really liked boxers, but
they're just too big. I mean,
why don't I just live with a pony at that?
Oh God, what a fucking week I
had, man. What a fucking week.
I had just stayed home for the holidays.
I had the best and the best time
it was calling everybody up,
wishing everybody merry Christmas.
I was in the best fucking
mood because I was home.
You know, I didn't have to fly anywhere.
And I'm telling you people out there,
don't let your parents guilt you any more
into the fact that you have to go home
for the holidays. You
don't, you don't visit them,
visit them during different times of the
year when the whole world isn't flying
back to the east coast or out the fucking
Wisconsin or wherever the fuck you
going.
I'm telling you,
you don't have to put yourself through
it and then he can just sit there and
watch the news and you see those people
sleeping on the airport floor and you
can just laugh your ass off just knowing
that that could have been you and now
it isn't. And now someone
else is you and it's not you.
And you can laugh at you while not
feeling the pain. That makes sense.
I hope it did.
I'll tell you what doesn't make sense
as a fucking New England patriots or 11
and five and the San Diego
chargers are eight an eight
if fucking eight games better than, than
lions. And they are in the playoffs. Oh,
that's sad. Sack fucking organization.
They just can't buy a break. You know,
even though the,
they kill the Broncos and then at the
end of the game with Damion Thomas and
still fucking engines themselves,
you know, I don't know.
I don't know where I'm
at with the charges.
I hated them a few years ago when they
blew that game and then they started
calling the patriots a
classless organization. You
know what I mean? It's like, oh,
really? You guys with your
fucking convicted steroid user?
Who does is taunting dance
the entire fucking game.
Then he'd get mad cause
our players taunt him back
in know Jesus Christ and just
fucking babies. You know,
you fucking net poor excuse for
a football stadium. You have, uh,
that left over concrete from the
highway that they molded into a stadium
back when Jimmy Carter was in office.
And he just fucking annoy me.
They annoy me and, uh, I don't know. Okay.
This is my big sleeper pick for
the, uh, for the NFL. I think, uh,
the Carolina Panthers are going to
surprise people. I like Jake alone.
I remember how that guy played in the
Superbowl years ago against the Patriots.
And I think they got enough.
I think they got enough to go
deep into the playoffs. And,
um, I dunno about the giants.
Giants looked great, but
it's just so hard to repeat.
Um, I dunno how you guys
doing in Dallas, Huh?
Jesus Christ. That was a raping.
That really was no loop either.
That was just fucking, I was done. I was
brutal and it was really brutal. I Dunno.
I Dunno about that Tony Romo. Um, anyway,
let's plow ahead here.
You want to something,
I'm actually in a great mood
despite the fact that this happened,
I went to pink's hot dogs.
Now for those of you who don't live in
Los Angeles and he never been to Los
Angeles, they got this fucking, ah,
they got this hotdog stand, okay.
That evidently has the greatest hotdogs
that you'll ever taste in your life.
But every time you drive by there,
there's literally, I mean, I'm not joking.
There's like 80 people in line.
I went there and when I first came out
here the first week and I literally stood
in line for like an hour for a hot dog.
So I was like,
well that was fucking stupid. I'm never
doing that again. And Lo and behold,
for some reason I went to go pick up my
lovely girlfriend from work and someone
at work had mentioned to
her about pink's hot dogs.
So she got a craving and she was like,
oh my God,
can you take me a pig's hotdogs?
I T I don't know if somebody dementia,
I just want, you don't want girls get like
that. And it would just look adorable.
And they deliberately act like they're
like a little kid and you just,
you just can't fucking resist it.
So I'm like, all right sweetie,
I'll take you over to get you a hot dog.
We pull up in the line is like two and
a half times longer than it usually is.
It's literally wrapped all the way around
this fucking tin shack, by the way.
It's a tin shack.
All right?
It's on Labrea in Melrose and I'm
giving you guys some great advice.
Don't ever fucking go there. All right?
So I'm like, you know, I just laugh.
I'm like, this is ridiculous.
I'm bill. I'm like, you know
what? It's the holidays.
I didn't fly.
I'm not sitting in an airport.
I'll stand in this fucking
line just to continue to,
to do the tradition of me standing in
fucking lines that I really don't need to
be standing in around Christmas.
So I stand in this fucking line
and this is the funny part.
We get their right standing in line and
as he's four Asian dudes in front of me
and was standing there for 15 minutes,
the line may be moved like six feet.
So finally one of the
agents, dudes, you know,
mumbles something in Cantonese or
whatever the hell he was talking and he
fucking walks up to the front of the
line and he comes back. And you know,
I don't know if you know this about me,
but I'm not bilingual.
And I certainly don't speak Chinese,
but I know what this kid said and
his hot talk, I thought, don't,
I'll fucking language. He just said,
dude, you gotta be shitting me. Fuck this.
This is just hot dogs. It's not
worth it. That's what he said.
What the honkytonks and his
language and I, I, you know,
I told them and they are the
other three Asian dudes laughed,
looked at each other,
nodded and made the smart move.
They got the fuck out of the line.
They got out of the line and
my dumb ass was like, oh great.
I get to move up another
half foot stupid bay. Right.
I stay on them for like another half hour.
We're freezing our ass off to the point.
My girl has to go to the car.
She gets to the car and somebody writing
us $145 a ticket because evidently it
became a toso after four o'clock so she
starts freaking out because we got to
move the car. She's like, forget
it, forget it. Let's just leave.
And at this point I'm stubborn. I'm
like, no, fuck that. I got $145 tickets.
Got Damn and I'm at least going to
get a fucking hot dog out of this.
So I had to pull the car into the lot.
I stand there for
like another hour and hour and a half.
I'm finally turning the corner to get
to the front of the Tin Shack for a
fucking hot dog. I can't feel my
toes. I'm jumping up and down.
I'm doing a little boo
ballistic fucking movement here.
Trying to keep the blood
in the extremities of my
body for fucking hot dog.
I'm already down 145 bucks,
but I'm going to see this thing through
and just when I thought it couldn't get
any worse, this we're right at the
corner of liberal, real Bria and Melrose.
So at every red light people are just
staring at us like we're in an exhibit of
fucking idiots looking at us the exact
way they should be looking at us.
Like, why would you stand in line for
two hours? It's a fucking hot dog.
You can buy packs of eight of them
at the grocery store. Take them home,
grill them up, and you know you
don't even have to stay on hold.
What are you doing? So this lady
basically rolls down the window.
It's alternative comedian looking fucking
twat sticks their head out the window
and starts dripping with sarcasm goes
you guys standing in line for hot dogs,
right? Just dripping with
sarcasm. There's nothing else.
There's nothing else on that corner that
we could be doing dripping with sarcasm
and the fucking democratic demographic
of shitheads that were in the line.
Do not hear the sarcasm and actually
answer her question like she was being
serious. This, this one guy's like, yeah.
So then she goes,
are they good?
Just dripping with sarcasm and this other
guy answers the question [inaudible]
nothing on Hassan choose the country.
And at that point I just hung my
head in defeat going, you know what?
I fucking deserve this. I really want
to get mad at that girl in the car,
but I can't. I can't.
She's absolutely right.
She's actually trying to help us right
now to let us know how fucking stupid is
what we're doing. And I, I just,
I just hung my head and I stood in
fucking line and I swear to God,
I ended up getting up there and I'm
looking at the hot dogs and you know what?
I forgot,
they don't even toast the Bun.
They don't even toast the fucking bun and
you just, they just stick it on there.
And if you have to cheese, they just
sprinkle some cheese on it. You Chile,
they just put Chili on it and then you
go into the shack and there's no heat.
So you still cold
and you eat basically a ballpark frank.
And you stood in line for two hours and
you know, I'm one of these fucking guys,
man. It just, I swear to God,
you know, that fool me once,
shame on you fool me
twice, shame on me. I,
you literally fool me like nine times
before I finally start picking up on it.
And now I finally, I
finally realized it. Okay,
if you come out here to Los Angeles and,
and you know, and you ask people, Hey,
what do you do out here?
And somebody suggest to you,
oh, you got to go to pinks.
You got to go to pinks and get a hot dog
man, or the best fucking hot dogs. No,
they say that shit just
slowly draw your right.
Let me maybe going to be a lefty.
Maybe lefthand.
I Dunno what drive back overhand.
Right. Overhand left. Right.
Right into their mouth.
Don't even hit that note.
Just put it right in their fucking mouth
because that's what I'm trying to say.
It's overrated. Okay. And those of
you who aren't new to my podcast,
I do underrated. Overrated. That is my
big overrated thing of the fucking week.
Alright. Pink's hot dogs and La
Sucks. A big bag of fucking elk dick.
I've walked into fucking four star
restaurants and they've been like, I go,
how long is the wait Deanna innovation
know how long is the way it's going to be?
About 45 minutes. And I always look
at the person I'm with and we'd go,
you know what? Fuck that. Fuck that. I'm
not doing that. I don't give a shit if,
if, if Mario Batali is cooking
the meal, I'm not standing.
I'm not here for 40 I'll go get a slice.
I don't give a shit.
And I stood in line for two hours for
Goddamn hotdog and got a $145 ticket.
Okay. All right, I got that out.
Alright, that's it. You know,
that's been my week and I'm still
actually in a decent mood despite the fact
that my 11 and five patriots are
not in the playoffs. All my God,
what a week of sports.
And then the Celtics lost to the Lakers,
which was actually a great game.
Hopefully foreshadowing
another great NBA finals.
But I gotta tell you something.
I don't think I've ever laughed harder
in my life than watching Pau Gasol,
whatever his fucking name is
that Kenny Loggins looking
Croatian Jackass fucking pump
hitting his fist off his chest.
Every time he hit a lay up, what the
fuck was he doing during that game?
I thought he's going to start
singing the theme of the titanic.
It's fucking running down
the court like Celine Dion.
Every time he hits the shot,
what the fuck did he really thought?
He proved something, didn't he? Yeah,
I guess you showed us, you know,
you disappeared during the finals and
didn't get a championship ring buoy.
Watch out for Pau Gasol during a
regular season game in December.
You know that that's what's wrong
with sports. You know what I mean?
Act like you've been there.
Okay.
Act like you've been there
and when you fucking winter,
regular season game after
choking in the NBA finals,
don't fucking start pounding your chest.
You know when this 50 games left in
the season, what a fucking moron.
But I that he did it,
him and that other guy with the,
with the hairdresser haircut, when he
hit that layup and he just starts fucking
pounding his chest, like he
said, Braveheart, you know,
like he just ran over a hill with blue
paint on his face and just defeated an
army twice the size of his in a lay up,
get back on defense jackass.
Ugh.
I really hope that that pissed the
Celtics off. I know it did. I know it did.
And that's only, it's only going to help
us out. That fucking, who is that guy?
That guy with his hair cut.
They're talking about how he
just chose each other would even,
we agreed on Christmas. They
totally j hate this joke. Oh yeah,
I guess you showed them, you know, green,
you know is also a part of nature.
It's a part of Christmas.
It doesn't have to mean Celtics,
but if you want to ruin your holiday
and wear blue man. Um, but whatever
note, you know, my biggest thing is, uh,
I liked, uh, what's his face there?
Andrew buying a man. That guy is the shit.
You know,
I didn't see any fucking chest pumping
from him and he could fucking put both of
those two other jackasses and fucking
snap him over his knee like a couple of
number two pencils and he wasn't
thumping his chest. He scared me.
He had a quiet confidence about him.
Those other guys look like a cup.
You know what they look like.
You have to see,
like when the spazz in elementary school
finally decides to fight back, you know,
you've been flicking them in the back
of the year for like three periods in a
row and he finally decides to
fight and you want to respect him,
but you can't cause he's making those
spazz noises as he throws punches like,
and he's like half crying.
That's what those two jackasses look
like fucking pumping you goddamn fucking
just, I really wish I could
remember the titanic song.
I'd fucking start singing it now even
though I know I can't sing as I proved a
couple of podcasts ago. All right,
let's get into the podcast here. Um,
the new year's resolutions.
Okay.
Last week I talked about my new year's
resolution. If you new to my podcast,
my new year's resolution,
um,
for next year is I'm not going to
tip when I get bad service. Okay?
And at a, at a, at a restaurant,
I've been doing that religiously no
matter what the guilt that I always have,
I have to tip 20% no matter
if you actually drop my
piece of cheesecake on the
fucking floor, you know, and spit
on my fork. I still give you 20,
20% and I'm not doing it anymore. All
right? If you suck, I'm not tipping you.
I can't just like not tip, but you
know, you're not doing your fucking job.
You suck. All right, so here,
that's my new year's resolution.
If you give you give me a bad
service, I'm not tipping. Um,
that's when I always hate to like
in a like what's like celebrities?
Have you noticed that? Like
in like, um, and whatever.
Like I'm one of those, like those,
those, those celebrity blog things or,
or page six in New York
there'll be like lagoon.
Ted Danson was at a diner and evidently
his finances aren't looking too good,
is he tipped 4%.
You know,
at no point did they ever think
maybe that the, the service sucked.
Maybe ask for cheese and scrambled
eggs and they didn't give it to him.
And then he sent them back and then they
did what they did was took a cold piece
of cheese and just slapped it on top
and just gave it back to him that way.
And maybe he was a little bit miffed
and maybe that's why he didn't tip
immediately go, oh, he's
famous and he doesn't tip.
He's achieved. Fuck. You know,
cause I'm miserable
with my own life and um,
so I'm going to attack the celebrity.
I Dunno if Ted Danson never
got busted for not tipping,
but you know what the fuck I'm saying.
So anyways,
here's people's New Year's resolutions.
All right. Um, New Year's resolutions.
I want to make a conscious effort to
connect with the people around me because
human relationships are vital and I've
been too quick to take them for granted
or dismiss them all together.
When I stopped to think about what,
of what I value most of my life,
it's all the memories,
good and bad with my friends and families.
That's what makes life worthwhile.
You know what?
That was actually really nice,
but because of my choppy
out loud reading skills,
that's why I could never host the 700
club because that fucking big headed
jackass could have read that email with
his eyes closed through the last third
of it are already getting ready to
be like, praise Jesus. Praise Jesus.
Let me see if I can do that.
Like the guy on the 700 club and this one
here comes from Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Praise God, praise God for Chattanooga,
Tennessee and his new year's resolution.
Is this lowered.
I want to make the conscious effort to
connect with the people around me because
human relationships, Archie is
so, so vital to me and I lowered,
I apologize, I've been too quick to take
them for granted or just dimiss dismiss,
then fuck,
dismiss them altogether.
And when I stopped to think about
what I value most of my life, Jesus,
it's all the memories, good and bad. Even
when you challenged me, it's still good.
All the memories,
good and bad with my friends and family.
That's what makes my life worthwhile.
You know?
I think he made a very good point there.
I think a lot of times and laugh,
we do forget things that are most vital
and everybody's talking about getting a
new guitar hero or the latest iPhone.
Those are just gadgets. Paypal,
if you really think about it,
did Jesus have any gadgets? Hey,
he didn't even have any fucking shoes.
You didn't hear him bitching.
He was too busy putting
his hands on a leper. Okay?
So I want you all to put your hands on
the TV screen right now. Pray with me,
probably of me. Just pray with me right
now. Please. Lower gees class my savior.
Please help me to remember relationships
in my life. They're so, so very vital,
okay? And how I have a pot to piss
in. And even though the bankers,
she is still three cores. If $1
trillion, I don't give a fuck.
I'm just happy because some day when I
die and I'm in the ground and the worms
are eating in my eye sockets,
I'm going have a couple of wings and I'm
gonna be flying around in the clouds.
Praise Jesus.
And please seem your contributions
to the 700 club so I can get the,
the crow's feet taken off my face
cause I spent half the show squinting.
All right. See I can read out
loud. I can read out loud.
I just have to get into praise Jesus. All
right, new year's resolution number two.
Um,
number two,
I am going to stop dwelling on all the
garbage of the past and look forward to
the garbage of the future.
All right, that's uplifting.
Um, I really thought I was going
to get more new year's resolutions.
I guess people didn't wait.
I have one other one in there.
I thought I did somebody saying that they
weren't going to do the hacky going to
the gym thing. That's the worst. Oh
look at me. I'm clicking on that.
I'm clicking on the computer again. We
did find out what the clicking noise was.
That was me doing that. I'm going to
stop doing that because it bugs people.
Although somebody was so miserable,
told me to keep doing it because he
enjoys when I annoyed people. Um,
last week I talked about going to the
movie milk and saying I really enjoyed it,
but I actually was avoiding the movie
because of all my straight friends kept
saying it's a great movie,
but I gotta warn you there's a
lot of male kissing in it. And um,
I was just talking about how,
you know,
that was something that was actually
pushing me away from that movie.
And I was like, does that make
me homophobic? I don't think so.
I just think,
you know,
I don't think it's anything wrong for
another man and another man to lock lips.
I personally just don't want to look at
it and I certainly don't want to pay $10
to see it. Um, so this guy says, ah,
this guy I think put me straight here.
He said,
I understand that the sight of two men
kissing makes you slightly uncomfortable.
I feel the same way. The reason for
this is that you are heterosexual.
That being said,
I think you may be taking it a bit far
to let it stand in your way of enjoying a
movie. Just because something
is uncomfortable to watch.
Doesn't mean it ruins the movie.
I find it marginally uncomfortable
to see someone get tortured.
But I'm not going to write off a whole
movie because of that and the porn
analogy. That's actually a
great point because yeah,
I would never want to get tortured,
but I've seen a bunch of movies where,
you know, guys get tortured and that type
of thing. But uh, but you know something,
I can actually argue that point because,
you know,
when I watched lethal weapon and
I watch Mel Gibson, you know,
dislocated his shoulder,
I know that it's not real.
He's not really dislocating
his is a shoulder.
But when you go to see milk,
um,
that guy's really kissing
that other guy really,
really kissing that other guy.
All right,
so, but I understand what he's saying.
He is right on a certain, I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know if
this is the whole fucking Oprah.
Let's turn guys into a puddle of Mush.
You think John Wayne would go see milk?
You know,
I'm not going to go see another
guy fucking another man. See?
Oh God. That was a terrible impression.
All right, here's the second half of his,
uh, his analogy and the porn
analogy you made while hilarious,
was somewhat inaccurate.
Okay.
Gotta be open to this criticism.
I'm not going to lose my temper. Um,
he says when I watch
porn, I jack off. However,
I do not check off every time a man
and a woman kisses on screen during a
regular film. In fact, I
usually go boneless. God dammit.
That's a good point.
Likewise,
I imagine gay men Jack off
while watching gay porn,
but not necessarily in the
middle of Brokeback mountain.
Um, I'm going to argue with you on
that one. I'm going to argue with,
don't let me do on that one. I bet. Um,
I bet a lot of gay guys did jerk off
to that even though I didn't watch that
movie once again because I didn't
want to watch two guys fucking a 10th.
Um, and not even that, even if it
was a man and a woman fucking intent,
I wouldn't go see it because it's
basically a chick flick and I really don't
care about watching two people
make a relationship work. Um,
speaking of which,
have you guys seen that new movie coming
out with Leonardo Dicaprio and that fat
chick from the titanic?
That's so mean. Um,
that little fullback with the
big head from uh, the titanic.
I'm really being mean during
the holiday season. Um,
have you seen the thing
like, I guess, you know,
they had two people with dreams and then
they moved out to the suburbs and then
they have a kid and then they just start
yelling at each other about how awful
their life sucks and they have all this
dramatic music and that's another movie
I'm not going to be able
to see because the entire,
I can't go see it in public because I'm
going to ruin it for the people around
me because the entire time I'm just
going to be yelling at the screen,
you know, why don't you
just move, sell your house,
go back to the city. It's a free
country. You're able to do that. Hello?
I mean I'm, what am I going to watch 90
minutes of them yelling at each other.
I even want Tupperware honey.
Okay.
He wanted an Ottoman,
not me. Feel wanted it
and him fucking punching a
cupboard right near her head.
And I just, you know, move,
get divorced. You know, I,
I've really learned that about anger is,
is that's when a lot of anger is when
you feel powerless in the situation and
you're not powerless.
You have the intelligence to make the
decision to get out of a bag. I mean,
I know it's not that easy, but
you know, but anyways, you know,
I want to come in that guy
who sent in all that stuff,
he really made some great
points. Um, you know,
I think you made some good
points, but like, ah, yeah,
there's a big part of me while I still
feel like I'm right. I mean, I don't know.
Do I want to get comfortable
watching two guys out? We'll go,
let's see. What am I afraid of? The
obvious. Then I'm going to watch that.
It's going to turn me gay. Stupid.
All right. You know what Mike Flynn,
you're fucking right. Okay. You're right.
You're God that you're absolutely right.
And, uh, you said Ts. Fuck the Bruins.
Well, you can say that all you want to,
they're like fucking 27 five.
All right, which one's your team?
Exactly. Let you sit there
and deal with that. All right.
Um, what do we got next? Movie
reviews. Movie reviews. No,
I did this last week.
Jesus Christ.
This is why you always see the clicking
sound because I'm not organized.
Okay, here we go.
Underrated. Overrated. Okay.
I think you guys know not to go to
pink's hot dogs at Labrea and Melrose.
Do not go there and feel free to make
fun of the people who stand in line at
pink's hot dogs because evidently
we don't understand sarcasm.
So you know,
do anything you want.
Stick your head out the window and just
be as sarcastic as you want and they
will just answer your questions.
You know what?
That's the big thing that you should
just drive by and heckle the people at
Pink's hot dogs.
I think I'm going to do that next time,
which is very hypocritical
because I stood in line last week.
I want to go down there and protest them.
Just have a sign and just be like,
you know, it's, they're not
that good or it's not worth it.
Or maybe I'll just yell out obvious
shit just to hear people answer it,
aren't you called?
Yeah.
Um, all right. Overweighted
if we go over rated,
this person says this week overrated.
Owen Wilson over 1 billion
in box office. But, but the,
but uh, Jesus Christ, I can't read
out loud. This is actually funny.
Let me go back to the beginning to
restart the comedy momentum. Okay.
Overrated.
Owen Wilson over 1 billion in box office,
but does this Douche bag
really make anyone laugh?
This guy makes cute movies like
wedding crashers and Rushmore. Both.
Cute but not funny.
I will never bust a gut laughing
watching this crooked nose. No talent.
And why do they always pucker
his lips in every promo shot?
I'll leave that to your imagination.
Wow.
He's going after Owen Wilson didn't that
guy just tried to kill himself a few
months ago. You know, I think he tried to
kill himself because he, he keeps making,
yeah, he makes these cute little movies.
Remember that you, me and dupree,
I mean that the, the, the fucking
title or that movie alone,
you know it's going to
suck. And you know, he's,
he's got another one of those coming out.
None of those kind of movies.
You mean to pre meet you and Magoo? He
just, he just know they're going to suck.
You're going to Improv and the crew's
going to be laughing cause they're afraid
not to laugh because you're
famous after each take.
I think he popped his lips so
maybe you don't look at his nose.
I think that that's what he does.
Or maybe he's like coming to the
realization that he's actually in a movie
called you, me and dupree. It rhymes.
That'll get them, you know
what? I bet you I, you know,
I don't even know how to
look up box office numbers.
I bet. I bet it did. Great.
You know, I, this is, I
know what I think why,
like guys like that ended up killing
themselves because I think you've very
subtly get taken off track
in this business and you
forget who you are and why
you ever even gotten this business.
And I actually had that feeling last
night when I was watching one of those,
uh, cooking shows. I basically
watched football all day,
watch my patriots do what they had
to do and then I want you to fucking
fumbling, bumbling, stumbling jets,
kill my fucking post season.
Um,
so yeah, I watched eight
hours of football, so at that
point it my girls, so like,
okay,
it's my turn.
So she puts on the cooking network and
I'm watching one of those iron chef shows
and some, some sort of throw down.
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but I'm watching Bobby flay and a,
you know,
pretty famous Goddamn chef with his
own TV show already and all his own
restaurants. Any standing there
getting judged by these jackasses,
just regular people going, you
know, I thought the falafel,
the outside was a little too greasy
while the inside was a little too flaky.
And I'm just sitting there looking at
the expression on his face and he really,
it really comes one of those moments like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I don't need to do this.
Why did I get into this business I got
in this business because I love to cook.
I like to cook. I like
to make people, you know,
make a little money off the
shit and make people happy.
Just eat my food and shut the
fuck up. Why am I, what am I,
why am I standing here is
just construction worker.
Is His fucking critiquing my
falafels you don't, it was,
it was,
uh,
John Starks from the Knicks
was critiquing. Actually,
he liked his flat. I don't know who
the fuck it wants. Some Queen Latifa.
I don't know the fuck it was, but
it was almost feels like, dude,
you didn't have to go through this
fucking humiliation. You already made it,
you know, and you're standing
here on TV and that they're,
they're filming your fucking humiliation.
And I think that that's what
happens to guys like Owen Wilson.
He got into this business.
No one gets in this business to be in me,
you and dupree you want
to make on the waterfront.
You want to be in the next
Godfather, whatever you want,
you want to do that shit.
But what happens? You've got a mortgage
payment. He got shit you have to do,
you know, all your relatives and
third cousins know you're famous.
So the very least you got to buy them all
iPods for Christmas. That costs money.
And next thing you know you're,
yeah, you're in me, you and Magoo.
And that's still only about
he can have on your face,
sort of put puckering up your lips.
Like, it's not like, you know,
do you want to kiss me?
And so like, Ooh, Ooh,
they guess this one's gonna suck. Sorry
about this one guys. I swear to God,
the next one's going to be a
little more artistic, you know,
and then you look,
somebody asked for an hour and a half
and somehow that ends up in the paper and
they call you the butterscotch stallion.
And the next thing you know,
I don't know. I don't fucking
know. I don't even know what,
I don't even know what any of
that even meant. But uh, yeah,
I wouldn't say that.
That guy's overrated.
I think you know he's a actually is
because this will just keep making money.
I think he's a good actor, but he doesn't
make good movies. All right. Underrated.
Um, this guy says the
movie, the last dragon,
anything with two lead
characters named shown enough.
The shogun of Harlem and
Bruce Leroy has my attention,
my ads or admiration. Once again.
What's your, what the fucking guy wrote?
I mean,
you know what I mean?
You guys are going to have to start
getting like leaving me voicemail messages
and then I'll just press play cause I
cannot read out loud to save my life.
Alright, overrated. Um,
find my space bitches sending you
invites to join them at clubs,
record release parties or New Year's
events. I'm not really gonna meet them.
And what am I going to say if
I do meet them? Like good boy,
you put my mind space Dan coming.
Oh we you exactly.
You might as well go stand in line for a
fucking hot dog at pink's. Um, you don't,
half the time it's not even,
it's not even the person you know,
choose usually some fucking fat bald guy
who just takes some random picture of a
girl with a bikini, you know? All
right, here's another underrated guy.
I liked this one. Somebody said,
Billy squire is underrated.
It gets no client. His music gets
no classic rock radio play anymore.
But tell me that. Don't
say no, doesn't kick ass.
And I don't know.
I don't know about Billy squire squire.
He's kind of like drew Bledsoe. You
know, he sorta has hall of fame numbers,
but he never, he never won a
ring. You know, I don't know.
Let's, let's see. He further defense and
let's see what else he has to say. Said,
admittedly it's not as in the
same league as back in black. Yes,
exactly.
But when lonely in the night or the stroke
or mind kind of love or unexpectedly
do get radio airplay,
you blast the car stereo.
All right. I gotta tell you
something. When the stroke comes on,
I actually turn it down a little bit.
I'd have to be in the middle of the
Berkshires somewhere in the middle of
nowhere to actually turn that song.
It just,
I don't know that song.
Uh,
I think if you're in seventh grade,
that's song holds up, you know,
and in that hand, yeah. Heard
stroke mi stroke me. I mean,
eat guys, he's a rock star.
He really still just getting the hand
jobs and I don't get it. Um, I bought,
I got to say the drummer and Billy
Squire's band did the best John Bonam
impersonation I ever heard.
And I actually looked him
up one time on the Internet.
I found out that he actually
passed away. So, uh,
arrest and peace drummer from Billy
squire. All right, here's his,
yeah. Isn't that Nice during the
holidays? All right, Bill. No.
What's really underrated. I
like this one. How do she,
someone comes off when they say
they liked the foreign film.
All right,
here's his story.
This guy I work with who likes to try
and sound cultured cause he sees these,
these uh,
these independent Philly's foreign movies
that won best picture at the Albanian
film festival if some shit like that.
And everyone he talks and
every time he talks up a movie,
it just sounds like a moving
only a douche bag would enjoy.
But what makes it worse
is what he'll totally is.
That'll totally dismiss any movie
that sounds that anyone else likes.
I recently saw the wrestler with Mickey
work and I was telling someone at work
that it was,
it was pretty good and right
away this douche chimes in going,
you went to see a movie about wrestling.
This comment from a guy who watched the
three hour movie about some old man who
likes to make pottery and he had to
read the whole thing because it was,
the dialogue was in Turkish by
the way. It goes. See Wrestling.
You don't have to like wrestling to
appreciate the story. Exactly. Um,
all right. First of all, just because
it's a foreign film and you have to,
you know,
read subtitles doesn't mean it's sucks,
but that also doesn't
mean that it's great.
And just because of movies about wrestling
doesn't mean it's sucks because this
guy is absolutely right.
I saw the wrestler to fuck,
I think it's a really good
movie and Mickey Workers.
Great. And um, I don't know.
Go see it back. Come on,
let's make you Brooke.
What did the guy put on 40 pounds
of muscle? Wink, wink. You know,
anybody else out there? Work out. How
much protein do you have to ingest? Wink,
wink to put on 40 pounds of muscle.
But then again,
those wrestlers put on 40 pounds of muscle
muscle. Wink, wink. So he did the same.
He was method acting. He did what he
had to do to put on 40 pounds of muscle.
And I looked pretty good in the
tights. They're all right. Uh,
here's a question or the weekend and
I'm going to wrap up this podcast just
because,
um,
I listened to last week's podcast is I
was fixing some things on my page and I
thought it went along way too long.
I think somewhere
around a half hours, a good
amount of time. All right.
[inaudible] question
number one, Bill. As a,
a former member of planet fitness and
having a moral obligation a few weeks ago,
I had no choice but to quit planets.
Uh,
what am I doing here is just overrated,
underrated.
See, I, I just, I'm just disorganized.
All right. I started reading it tonight.
I have to read it. What is this? Planet
fitness disappoints me on several levels.
First off, all their franchises,
branch branches, paint. Most,
if not all the floor equipment.
Uh, gay, purple and yellow color.
Oh, this is a guy trying to say
that all gyms are gay now. And,
uh, um, is there a question
at the end of this? Okay.
What ever happened to real gyms? Okay.
Yeah. The equipment is painted a gay,
purple and yellow color.
Yeah, just like the Lakers.
Oh to comfort sensitive people that
are intimidated by muscle heads and or
fitness clubs or reality in general.
And that is gay.
I think by gay he means stupid.
And what is even more gay is the fact
that you're not allowed to have a barbell
on the floor.
That means no dead lifts,
free standing squats and separate that.
Doesn't that mean don't leave the bar
there? Cause they don't want to be sued?
I Dunno. And it's not like
when others I work out with,
we are intentionally trying
to intimidate people.
We're not acting like Hulk Hogan did back
in the day to excite a crowd before a
match. I'm five eight 160
pounds of scared white meat.
I had to quit because I don't want to
be converted anymore into a pussy by
conforming to their lame rules.
I didn't know what the fuck.
You know what half of this is might
me not being able to read out loud
as corporate America's comforting.
Most Mormons in this country,
they are also eradicating conventional
wisdom in American culture to increase
their revenue regardless of repercussion.
La Fitness sucks balls to actually see,
I don't know what,
what am I having to the real
gems. There's this question. Ah,
there are real gyms and you go there
and you lay on the floor to do a fucking
setups. In the next day
you have some sort of rash,
like you're on the ultimate
fighter and then they have them.
They don't mop down there. Fucking
Matt's enough. I'm number two.
I'm sorry I butchered that whole thing.
I apologize.
I'll send you a refrigerator magnet
or something. All right, Bill. Um,
you occasionally mentioned
having a girlfriend and you
recently went on a hockey
trip. Uh, yeah, I did. I
went on a three day trip.
I went to a home game
of the Calgary flames,
Edmonton Oilers and the Vancouver
Canucks. He, she, he goes,
I assume she did not go along.
What kind of obstacles did you
have to hurdle to avoid a hearing?
A bunch of stupid girl
complaints about that trip.
I didn't have to hurdle any of them.
I have a great relationship because I
fought the battles I needed to fight so
that when I say I'm going on a
hockey trip, they can't be like,
oh see what does that me,
you don't care about me.
No, that's not what it means.
Is that what it means at all?
It means I like hockey and I want to
go on a trip. That's all it means.
See you on Monday. Yeah. No,
earlier in my, my dating career,
I used to have to go through shit
like that. But you know, you just,
you just have to have the
battles and you don't get,
don't scream and yell if you just
say in a very nice way. Listen,
I worked very hard this
year. You know, I've, I've,
uh, you know, done.
I'm not going to get until the intimate
details of shit that I've done. Okay.
I've earned the right.
Okay. I'm coming back.
I'm not going to go up there
and fucking bang an Eskimo.
I'm just going up there with, you know,
with some friends to go on a hockey trip.
There's no problems.
Okay.
Stop making me feel guilty
for doing something fun
and uh, that pretty much
ends it. In other words,
grow with Dick and your fucking
relationship and a, yeah, don't,
don't paint yourself.
If you're in a relationship right
now where you're not allowed to go do
something fun with somebody other
than the person you're dating,
you're not in a relationship,
you are actually a hostage.
And you need to get out of that situation.
You know, make a youtube video, blink,
SOS,
do whatever the fuck you have to do,
but get out of that relationship because
just get out of it because it's not
going to get better once you've given
up that territory. You know what I mean?
It's like all these Mexicans you
see protesting about, you know,
getting Texas back. You're not
getting it back. You know, it's over.
It's fucking done. You know, you
need to pick up a gun to get it back.
So put down your signs cause it's fucking
over. All right. Question number three,
uh, Bill podcast, quite a
podcast. What's the, okay.
One of my favorite things to do every
month is flipped a flipped to the back of
vanity fair to see if an artist,
I like his answer,
answering the Proust questionnaire.
Um,
whatever the fuck that is.
There are. Okay. Basically,
there are a slew of questions and I would
love to hear how you would answer all
of them. But for the purpose of this
email, I will only specifically ask,
what are your favorite favorite qualities
in a man and what are your favorite
qualities in a woman? Oh, okay. So this
is obviously a questionnaire where they,
they ask celebrities what
they're looking for in a mate.
What am I favorite qualities in a man?
Um,
he's not a Douche.
Uh,
he adheres to Guy Code,
which I'm not going to tell you what
that is because only men should know what
that is.
Um,
has a strong jaw orders for
me when I go out to dinner,
holds the door, act like a gentleman,
but isn't afraid of my opinions.
Um, yeah, I don't know. What am
I favorite qualities in a man?
Uh, I don't know. He eats
with his mouth closed.
You know, I don't like those fucking a
crow, like fucking half a caveman guys.
You know what I mean? Like those
guys like, uh, like morons.
I don't like hanging around with
dumb people, men or women and uh,
yeah, I, you know,
I like to be hanging out with the guy
who's in a relationship that he's happy to
be in so I don't have to listen to them
bitch about it or pretend to be happy in
it. Common sense stuff. And one of
my favorite qualities in a woman, um,
I like a woman who's, who's a neat
one of my biggest turn off of women's,
a women's. I don't, we don't,
I don't like about the women's is when
the bitches be messy. No, seriously.
A woman who's Messi is one of the biggest
turnoffs ever. You know what I mean?
That's like a guy who can't pick
up something heavy. You know,
if you're like a woman, you know, like,
oh, can you give me a hand with this?
And he like breaks a nail.
Like when that turn you off,
that's like ground zero of being a man
is you should actually have some sort of
physical strength and what the woman is,
they should know how to keep
the house clean. That's right.
I just said that and I don't
think that is sexist. All right.
I think that's one of the fucking
great things that a woman does,
teaches you how not to
live like a fucking animal.
It's one of the things that they're
allegedly naturally good at.
Although I find a lot of women to
be pretty fucking messy and I'm,
yeah,
I'm old school women who can cook
and clean and all that type of stuff,
you know? Um, I'm not saying
that I'm going to walk,
walk in like a cave man with mud on my
shoes and you should have to sweep up
behind me,
but like the same way women still want
guys to know how to be handy around the
house. Yeah. Women who
can cook or the shit.
Women with a sense of humor woman who
actually are into sports a little bit.
I understand. Most of you
think it's retarded. Yeah.
That type of Shit, you know,
and uh, I don't like
horse. I like classy women.
Women who live around. Yeah.
Classically beautiful. Yeah,
I dunno that type of shit and see,
know it's none of your fucking business.
All right.
After that was,
I just felt bad divulging
all that personal information
and I just felt like I
was opening up too much. I
got a little scared. Okay.
The very least in this podcast question,
you know, you got to listen to,
to doing there. My impression of the 700
club. All right, question number four. Um,
do you believe in God? If so,
how can you be so fucking stupid?
Um, you know, I actually
understand what you're saying that,
but I definitely do
believe in a higher power,
but I don't believe in it within
the context of organized religion.
Um, if that makes any sense. I definitely
believe in a higher power, something,
whatever it is. Like, I mean,
how the fuck did all this stuff get made?
But it's just so crazy.
I think that there's this big
thing that that made all of it in.
Where was he when he made it or
did he have to be in something
that had to be created?
I don't know what the fuck's going on,
but I know the answers are
not in organized religion.
That is just basically
an updated version of,
of cavemen paintings on the
walls. And uh, you know,
when people get really religious,
super, super religious,
they somehow get really angry and
they get violent and it leads towards,
and uh, yeah, I don't believe in
it, but I definitely, you know,
when I contemplate my own death,
I do get scared that I'm not a member
of any organized religion, you know,
so, uh, I dunno. I Dunno. I, you know,
I don't fucking know. I, I
believe in a higher power,
but I don't believe in it within organized
religion. Okay. The final question,
here we go. Number five, Bill,
is there any way to listen to on
the uninformed show you do on Xm?
I don't have an, an,
an an XM subscription,
but I did enjoy the live version you did
on opie and Anthony a couple of weeks
back while the one we did on opie.
And Anthony was on Xm, wasn't it?
Um, no, there's no way to
listen to it without that.
And we don't have the
money in the budget to, uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what we have to do with that.
That's something that's one of my New
Year's resolutions to somehow get it up on
the Internet.
For those of you new to the podcast,
I do this radio show on informed.
It's on Xm. I do it with Joe de Rosa.
We do a once a month or lately,
once every other month because shit
has been fucking weird. But anyways,
that is the end of the podcast.
Um,
I appreciate you guys all this year.
You know,
I just want to say thanks to everybody
for everybody sending in your questions
and uh,
you know,
your contributions to the podcasts are
the reasons why that it's now 50 minutes
long as opposed to the back in the day.
Remember back in the day when I used to
do it in a one room shack and I could
only talk for eight minutes and then
I'd have to hang up. Well thanks to you.
It works for all of us to build burn
Monday morning podcast. All right,
you guys have a very happy new year
and um, oh, there's one for you.
That's what I think is fucking
overrated is new years. It's,
it's,
it's the dumbest fucking thing ever.
I'm actually going to walk out and make
a peanut butter sandwich while I talk
about how overrated fucking new
years is this. This is bonus time.
You guys didn't have to listen to this.
This is like after the
game when you know who won
and you're listening to the postgame
analysis and there's really no reason to
fucking do that.
This is what this part of the podcast
is seen on obligated to listen to any of
that as I make a fucking peanut
butter sandwich. MMM. Look at that.
Does the parking tickets from a tank
sweat on my refrigerator? Just mocking me.
Huh? Mocking me and the awful
fucking hot dog that I done. Yeah.
You don't need to go out on new
years. You know, I've actually been,
cause I'm finally taking new years off.
I'm looking at all these regular bars,
you know,
of course my girl wants to go someplace
fancy so she has a place to where her
new year's dress,
which I totally understand,
but now all of these regular bars that
have like a fucking $10 cover charge,
it's all 40 bucks,
50 75 some places are leaving
even like 150 bucks to do what?
Go out and drink,
which you can do at home for free and
now he's standing next to fucking day was
jam packed. It's hot.
People with plastic hats,
those stupid fucking horns
blowing it in your ear.
That's how you really want
to bring in the new year,
getting completely overcharged for some
shit to stand with a bunch of other
douche bags. Three, two, one,
you know that's all overrated and all
you fucking scared whores out there whose
dads didn't stick around.
So you have low self esteem and you
drink too much and then you go into that
panic way like, oh my God, I, it's
new year's. I need someone to kiss.
I have to have someone to kiss. You
don't, don't give into peer pressure.
You know,
sweetheart,
if you want to wonder why you always end
up in the bathroom on your knees in the
stall. It's because you given to herd
mentality. You don't have to do that.
You don't, you don't need somebody to
kiss, but you need to do is contemplate,
you know,
the fact that you don't have someone to
kiss and that that's okay and that you
should hold out for someone who's going
to treat you good rather than drag you
in it into the fucking bathroom
at 1201 to make you fucking,
you know,
so you can suck your first deck of 2009
2000 oh nine 2009 you know what I mean?
I don't know.
You don't actually put jelly on it.
I've been trying to just do the protein,
but I had to put jelly on a
sandwich because you know,
you try to eat a peanut
butter sandwich and you know,
you dislocate your job by the time
you'd done shoe and all of it.
It's just a fucking pain in the ass.
So anyways,
thanks for listening to the podcast.
Everybody.
Please keep the questions coming and
it's not too late to send in your New
Year's resolutions.
And you know what?
I liked that a lot of people didn't
send any new year's resolutions.
You didn't follow the
fucking pack and make one.
You could make one anytime of
the year. And uh, that's it.
I'm in my little breasts, breakfast
Nook, and the sun is shining it
then I feel special.
Talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].